التركيز بالكامل منصب على نتيجه مجلسي
الشيوخ والنواب لكنه هناك نتيجه اخرى
تحتاج لالقاء الضوء عليها حكام وسكر
الولايات لا ننسى ان منصب حاكم الولايه
كان نقطه انطلاق 17 رئيسا لدخول المكتب
البيضاوي اي ان 40% من من حكموا الولايات
المتحده كانوا في الاصل حكاما لولايات
نتحدث عن بلتون جورج بوش الابن رونالدو
الجمهوري الذي لم يحدث في النواب والشيوخ
بالتاكيد لم يحدث ايضا في 36 ولايه اختارت
حكمها الجدد لكن ما اهميه دور حكام
الولايات في الواقع معظم الامريكيين
يرتبطون بحكوماته ولاياتهم ويتواصلون معها
اكثر من اتصالهم بالحكومه فيدراليه لان
ادارات الشرطه والمكتبات والمدارس تخضع
لاشراف الاولى
يتمتع غالبيه الحكام بسلطه تعيين قضاه
محاكم الولايات ايضا كما ان لهم سلطه
الدعوه لجلسات تشريعيه خاصه ويتمتعون كذلك
بسلطه استخدام حق النقض الفيتو ضد
الاجراءات التشريعيه برمتها
وهناك ايضا اهميه اخرى كبيره للادارات
المحليه للولايات فروما ان سباق
الى انه يقع على عاتق مسؤولين الولايات
والمسؤولين المحليين الاشراف على
الانتخابات واجراءات التصديق على نتائجها
وعلى عكس انتخابات الرئاسه التي تختار
خلالها الولايات ممثليها في المجمع
الانتخابي حيث يتم التصديق على النتائج من
قبل كونغرس يتم اعتماده النتائج النهائيه
في سباقات مجلس النواب والشيوخ في كل
ولايه على حده والعديد من الولايات لديها
سكرتير منتخب يمثل اعلى سلطه في
الانتخابات وهو الذي يصادق على النتائج